bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono parigi oggi siamo su
chi vi dico che mi vedete con questo
affare giù perché io comunicherò con
thomas tramite questo perché questo
gioco si gioca proprio in cooperativa in
cooperativa devi parlare con i walkie
talkie quindi io lui mi sentirà
attraverso story trovano un po perché il
gioco c'è un vero walkie talkie e quindi
non siamo in chat su di spicco su
dischord siamo in chat nel gioco
eccomi sono pronto ti sento veramente
rover come una patata ma va benissimo
allora noi ci parleremo attraverso
stolti tolti che ci sarà nel gioco
speriamo di non far pagare e via alla
nostra intelligenza
devi dire devi dire passo ogni volta che
finisci perché se non li a me quale chi
dall chi hai ragione ragione allora
freri aero capisco niente qua ho trovato
un muro con dei simboli che non saprei
come comuni cartelli perché sono
veramente strani però hai qualcosa con i
simboli passo o una roba che può
decifrare dei simboli te quindi posso
aiutarti corri answer l'ice vuol dire la
risposta giace la risposta me la devi
dare tu perché sono me la dai non so
come andare avanti quindi io devo darti
questi codici sicuro c'è questi simboli
tu mi devi dire che cosa fare in base
alla questi simboli qualche uscirà una
risposta che se non mi dici non andrò
mai avanti quindi adesso ti dico i
simboli dimmi come posso fare
dimmi se sei pronto passo l'altra parola
al trap a frase dalla mia parte è la
risposta già c'è e mezzo agli occhi
ochoa la roba per per decifrare pasto
quindi ok c'è un preciso ordine
tu mi devi dare un ordine di questi
simboli che vedi che saranno gli stessi
miei c'è tipo una m
una m strana una saetta una ics con un
cerchi in mezzo una specie di a del culo
che sta pisciando provato non so se è
corretto è una specie di a con dentro un
attivato passo ok allora c'è un albero
di e verso l'alto con una riga oppure
puoi immaginarla come un sedere che sta
facendo cose poi è esattamente quello
che ho detto prima passo poiché la
schiaccia ormai non funziona ok aspetta
ho aperto una porta da solo facendo a
caso passo ho schiacciato in ordine per
farti capire la ics con una sbarra in
mezzo ad un cerchio e poi dopo la con
una t in mezzo e si è aperta la porta
l'unica che era chiusa non idea di cosa
fosse perché io sto in una stanza con un
botto di quadri ma poi è tutto e meglio
da fare fare da solo con che con thomas
praticamente comunque sono passato alla
stanza successiva solo grazie al mio
culo e thomas sono in una stanza piena
di simboli anche io che devo schiacciare
evidentemente quindi aspetto secondo che
sono delle gru capitoli suo fidato non
sono schiacciati sono tipo delle carte
tool e prendi sono carteano ok c'è un
quadro con un pavone con la faccia da
teschio e le gambe le zampe da gallina e
sotto ci sono tre simboli quindi io devo
ammetterlo in 3d sottopasso ok ok cielo
reparto del diritto della ripeto la
frequenza con l'uncino e il mirino sopra
par
ok sperando di aver capito il gigante 2
è un tridente con sotto una cirov
capovolta la girata di 90 gradi e
aspettativa che mi è cascato
mirino quei rispettivi secondo per
favore passo
il secondo è un tridente con l'aci
inquinata di 90 gradi a destra
chiara è che questo è un tridente con
una c inclinata di 90 gradi a destra
sotto la parte sotto ho capito passo di
eva con l'ultimo l'ultima è una borsa
per la spiga di grano è un bastone verso
l'alto con due frecce tenevano le mani
che dovrete ha funzionato passo
bella bella bella bella che figo se lo
porti una donna non lo so me la cavavo
così anche a scuola ragazzi sempre
consigliandomi tra amici facendo
bigliettini allora siamo in una io sono
in una stanza dove ci sono dei tubi ok
c'è una porta vabbè poi sotto ci sono
delle scale che vanno a finire in
dell'acqua e c'è una porta con su
scritto orange arancione però la scritta
e colorata di rosa non e gli arancione
passo allora a me hai aperto un
seminterrato dove vado anch'io in
dell'acqua e o tre valvole una blu una
rossa e una gialla e sono in pieno
d'acqua io in questo momento dobbiamo
fare aiuto
non c'è niente qua come faccio a passare
avanti devo semplicemente stato così che
devo fare
dio si sta riempiendo tutto è thomas si
sta allagando tutto pasto aiuto oddio
oddio di allora spetta dobbiamo
selezionare le valvole giuste ma è la
prima e orange e thomas devi muoverti è
l'eroe c'è scritto orange aiuto aspetta
il fatto scorrere l'acqua non so come
sia possibile passo addio meno male
addio ci sono arrivato con tativo a
caldissimo bravissimo
bravissima ben salvato il culo stava
negando passo e tom sono in un corridoio
e basta ok si avverta tirala e torna a
quella verde quindi ieri a sinistra
dell'ingresso della mappa passo vi
stanno venendo i calcoli alle ginocchia
passo abbiamo finito abbiamo finire
l'ultimo putt softball
in tutto questo dei cani che vedevo di
quadri che cosa minchia servivano passo
devo tirare la verde tira la verde ti si
sblocca la porta e giri subito a
sinistra è finito ok miglia incredibile
sei anni per fare sta roba ci siamo raga
addio
eccoci ci sono passo dalla ii tac o mio
dio aperto che è finito ci sono gli
scacchi dei maghi passo vorrei parlargli
harry potter imi dopo la fiera e bianco
cosa devo fare
qual è il perone nere un'app andare
avanti con il pedone che hai fatto passo
ora con la reggina vai tutto dritto e
manzo il pedone nero di quello che sa
tutto dritto davanti a ok è definita
conti
batte lo passo scacco matto maledizione
e quindi c'è la porta allora tom sono in
una stanza dove a quanto pare secondo me
se clicco delle pedane in particolar
modo succede qualcosa quindi aspetta un
attimo che vedo se muoio non mi sembra
la cosa migliore per iniziare infatti
sono morto per la nota non mi ha ucciso
mi ha riportato all'inizio comunque devo
alla presente c'è una pedana ci sono
varie caselle no e tu devi passare su
ogni casella c'è un percorso che devi
fare per arrivare dall'altra parte
semplicemente solo che non so quali sono
le caselle giuste quali sono quelle
sbagliate
questo ti posso dire che ho un leggio
con cinque simboli strani passi da dove
è ripartito dovevi fare due caselle
verso in avanti lega sente si passò due
a sinistra come a sinistra a destra se
non è il far west a destra passo che
contamina a sinistra la sinistra
intendeva destra certo brava porco
dell'olio sbaglino ma è sbagliato ma
possibile però era una sola a destra
passo da a2a in avanti 2 a sinistra e
due in avanti di nuovo
ok passò poi a destra di uno quindi devi
tornare doveri prima due in avanti di
due verso nord ha funzionato
bravo pazzo
mannaggia alterata filastrocca maledetta
ma che bordello resto gioco non ora che
stiamo giocando
tom vedo un teatro passo cioè sento più
che altro un qualcuno che sta parlando
tra l'altro passo uguale uguale per me
non leghiamo cos'è c6 alla lezione di
all attivo se la tiro e sbagliamo tu non
pensare che abbiamo sbagliato
guardami se esce qualcosa se cambia
qualcosa perché quando io tiro la leva
le volte escono roma le volte no qui
adesso mi devi dire se io poi sbagliato
mi devi dire se è cambiato qualcosa di
posizione
perché se non è cambiato niente togliamo
l'altro rene ok non è cambiato nulla ma
si è accesa la luce basso attiva la blue
light un attimo e attiva adesso ok
perfetto ha detto prova far uscire ma
non ho tirato ancora niente dalle varie
la scena non l'ho tirata devo tirare ok
mai proviamo adesso sia ringraziata
cristo e basta mamma mia che ansia base
è finito che succede
sento un casino ok ottimo prova così all
ora e vai tutto giusto
ti prego io ti ringrazio
basta basta un giga ansia tom sentono
rumori orribili e c'è una botola che
faccio era la fine del
non lo sapremo mai cosa disse dopo aver
ucciso tutti ma credo fosse una cosa
molto brutta meglio non saperlo
va bene c'è una botola che faccio l'ho
presa
ok eccoci ti vedo ehi ma che bello che
sei anche tu che figo
io schiacciato a pedale 20 muoio ciao ha
davvero può uscire uno solo
non è che secondo me devi bloccare prova
tira su tutta la pedana wars the worst
friends è vero mi ha dato la gente wars
prender ok bellissimo questa è la we
were here
un gioco di amicizie vi dico che we were
here a due sequel e li faremo
nel frattempo vi ringrazio per avermi
seguito il video e ringrazio thomas
pensato canada che la sua descrizione e
niente
abbiamo proseguito un bacino
[Musica]